and the right guy on the mound to get
things
in the right direction and that is old
uncle charlie
adam wainwright and the o2 pitch from
adam wainwright
swing and a miss gets away from molina
tracks it down
fires his strike and the first out
the strikeout on three pitches and the
two-two
hit left side orinato had a couple of
dandies in semi-night baseball that
wrigley last night
and that's out number two incredible
market this day and age of baseball
line to third and a one two three inning
for the marlins it's braxton garrett
seventh overall pick by the marlins back
in 2016 out of high school this
is his second start here in 2021 his
third game however
and looking to bounce back after a loss
to colorado his last timeout
the pitch the fastball runs up and in
swung on a missed strike three in a
strikeout
to start the night for broxton garrett
and arenado lifts one back into shallow
left field it will be
jazz if it ever comes down it does
that's out number three a good first
inning
from braxton here there's sierra
239 no home runs no runs bad at end
the 1-1 into right center that ball
scooting and pass carlson backing up
tommy edmond quickly getting it back
into social
relay to the plate it is there and nine
times
he missed the play duval missed the
plate the tag applied by molina
[Applause]
he noticed that duvall apparently had
missed the plate
but did he well the plate is blocked
right there
certainly by yachty air molina's foot
and you called it damn what a heads up
play by
adam wainwright eye on that entire thing
knowing that he did not touch the plate
i think he's out that's just heads up
baseball right there
oh he's out first and second
and the batter will be sosa his pitch
a base set down the left field line for
sosa digging around third base
yadi and molina is trying to score the
throw
and yachty slides in safely an rbi
single for edmundo sosa
one nothing cardinals in the second
inning
adam into the wind up the 3-2 pitch is a
called strike three on the outside
corner
diaz doesn't like the call but that is
strikeout number two for adam
and he is sharp in the early going
that's inside for ball four back to back
walks and the marlins have him loaded
for tonight's cleanup man jazz chisholm
junior who has a chance to
well clean up right now and a ground
ball
into left field a base hit in comes
bertie
a second run will score and jazz
chisholm jr comes through
as bernie and marte score and the
marlins take a 2-1 lead
so two down after the lead-off hit by
carlson
bringing tyler o'neill to the blade he
struck out his
first time up and o'neal
scorches one toward the gap and left
center field that's going to get down
get to the wall
martay gets to it fires it in carlson
around
third throws off the mark and
we've done it again a runner that missed
home plate the first time around and
then the catcher goes back to apply the
tag
wow i feel like i've seen this before
because you have oh you have seen it
before
he missed home play clearly missed home
plate the first time
now here no now here's the thing i think
when larry van over you saw that safe
call
i believe that that safe call is to say
he didn't attack he did not touch home
plate
oh and he's out at the plate adam wayne
right now for the top of the fourth
inning
swaying and a miss strikeout number 1900
for adam wainwright 3-2 pitch
swing and a miss fair strikeout to the
ending for
adam wainwright all right top of the
lineup and trying to get something going
the cardinals
about hit the marlins 6-4 and they trail
by the score
of two to one and edmond hits a fly ball
into left
sierra over sliding it's off his glove
and a fair ball as it hops into the
seats and a ground rule double
so more traffic for the cardinals
tying run in scoring position to start
the fifth
up the middle birdie's there looks at
third throws to first
dugout by aguilar makes the play well
john bertie making a great defensive
play again
up the middle to take away a base hit
and the cardinals have a great chance
here to tie this game up at least
anthony bender is in right part of the
lineup up right guy
up right here the 2-1 pitch goldie
bass hit into left and the game is tied
at 2-2
oh goldschmidt drives in his 31st and
we're tied at 2.
nolan arnaudo has popped up and flied
out
to short jazz birdie
cardinals tie it defender limits the
damage
2-2 and it's shaping up like a typical
adam wainwright game too you give up a
couple of runs but then
settle down have a couple of quick
innings as he did in the fourth and
fifth and hopefully in the sixth
swing and a miss and strikeout number
six the pitch to him
he jammed him and there's a pop fly to
right field
and medium right tommy edmond makes a
one-handed catch
no runs no hits a walk and one left
adam simber
one and two in a 3.34 era
this is his 30th appearance that line
out to
center and sierra makes a sliding play
out there for out number two
the o2 pitch
stabbed at it throw behind and got him
heads-up play yachty and sosa
and it turns out to be a double play
a perfect throw it's almost like leading
the receiver
o'neal 262 with runners in scoring
position
o'neal with a drive deep left it is wall
sierra fields it cleanly relay to the
plate
not in time and scoring it is dylan
carlson and the cardinals have a 3-2
lead
tyler o'neill the devil to put saint
louis on top
an intentional walk to yada yada molina
to bring up
paul deyoung fisted up the first base
line but that will score a run
front lead you've got your closer alex
reyes on the bump
not a ton of safe opportunities here
lately for alex reyes in the cardinals
the 1-2 ground ball hit to short
the young has it across the diamond and
the cardinals win it
the final of four to two